one of the biggest mistakes i've made in
my life and i'm trying to get better at
it i never reached out to anybody for
like 10 years if i'm being very
transparent and vulnerable there was
definitely a part of me that'd be like
ah yes xyz reached out to me like i
liked it it felt like i accomplished
something i'm aware of that now
something really hit me kobe so
kobe passes and multiple people reach
out to me who were three weeks later
saying that they were in the process of
reaching out to me because in the last
six months he started really like liking
my content wanted to meet and i just
remember thinking talk about somebody i
really admire because i'm so competitive
everything he is as an athlete i
understand cold i understand and loved
competition i admired that mindset that
tenacity that accountability and he was
also nice and i'm just like man why
couldn't i have reached out and be like
hey really what you've done for these
years it's really cool and then maybe we
would have had dinner and i would have
that memory